y voy a hablarles de lo que es un macho alfa,
porque creo que podemos aprender mucho de nuestros parientes cercanos,
entre los que hay machos alfa.
Como ejemplo, quiero presentarles a Amos, un macho que conocí,
un macho alfa joven,
muy popular,
pero se enfermó
y perdió su lugar, porque los chimpancés machos
son capaces de detectar a la distancia si alguien está débil,
por eso fueron por él, y perdió su posición.
y fue enfermándose más y más
hasta que en un momento tuvimos que aislarlo.
El grupo vivía en una isla cubierta de pastizales,
y tuvimos que aislarlo en una jaula,
pero dejamos la jaula abierta para que los otros chimpancés
siguieran teniendo acceso a él.
Y lo que ocurrió entonces fue muy conmovedor.
Los otros chimpancés le traían comida,
le llevaban virutas de madera,
que suelen usar para acostarse y hacer sus nidos,
y las hembras le ponían las virutas detrás de la espalda.
Amos estaba recostado contra la pared,
y a modo de almohada, como si estuviera en un hospital,
le ponían ese material detrás de la espalda.
Y pensé: "Así es como se debe tratar a un macho alfa".
Era querido y respetado, y todos lo cuidaban,
pero no siempre es así,
porque algunos no terminan tan bien cuando pierden su lugar.
Amos era ejemplo de un macho que gustaba como líder,
y si buscamos el término "macho alfa" en Internet,
hallaremos libros de negocios que enseñan a ser un macho alfa,
es decir a cómo ser superiores a los demás,
cómo pasarles por encima y demostrarles quién es el jefe
y que no deben meterse con uno.
En este contexto, el macho alfa es básicamente un bravucón.
A decir verdad, es una descripción que no comparto
porque, en parte, soy responsable del término "macho alfa"
por ser autor del libro "La política de los chimpancés",
que recomendó Newt Gingrich a los miembros del Congreso.
Desconozco cuán útil les pudo ser, lo cierto es que se los recomendó.
y, desde entonces, el término "macho alfa" se popularizó mucho.
Pero considero que se lo interpreta de manera equivocada.
Se usa de una manera muy superficial
que no se relaciona con lo que es, en verdad, un macho alfa.
Por eso vine, para explicar lo que significa.
El término en sí mismo se remonta a mucho antes.
Se remonta a investigaciones con lobos en los años 40 y 50,
y la definición es, en esencia, muy sencilla.
El macho de mayor rango es el macho alfa.
La hembra de mayor rango es la hembra alfa.
Cada grupo de primates tiene un macho alfa, una hembra alfa,
no hay otro, es solo uno.
Les explicaré cómo funciona.
Veamos, en primer lugar, el lenguaje corporal.
Vemos aquí dos machos del mismo tamaño,
pero uno camina erguido, con el pelaje erizado,
tiene una gran piedra en la mano y es el macho alfa.
El otro macho le gruñe,
se somete a él y se inclina
y ese es el tipo de ritual que hacen varias veces al día
para poder mantener una relación estable.
Les mostraré un vídeo filmado en el lugar.
Vemos una hembra que le gruñe a un macho alfa
y observen qué sucede.
El macho se acerca,
ella le gruñe.
(El chimpancé gruñe)
El macho tiene el pelaje erizado
y presume ante la hembra.
Yo estoy allí, muy cerca de ellos.
Un chimpancé es mucho más fuerte que yo,
y no fui muy prudente con este vídeo en particular.
Lo que acaban de ver
es al macho erguido sobre sus dos patas,
abriendo los brazos.
Eso se llama pavoneo bípedo.
Es una postura muy común entre machos de alto rango,
y es reconocible porque los humanos también lo hacen.
(Risas)
Lo hacen todo el tiempo.
Lo que más me gusta de esta foto
son los dos hombres a los costados.
Esto es típico de los chimpancés.
En los chimpancés,
hay machos entrados en años
que ya no pueden ser machos alfa,
pero empiezan a hacer ardides y a formar alianzas
a espaldas del resto,
y se vuelven extremadamente influyentes.
Incluso puede haber machos ancianos
que tienen más influencia que el propio macho alfa.
Por ejemplo,
de estos tres machos, que son con los que más trabajé
hace tiempo en el zoológico holandés, en el que trabajé
el del medio es el macho alfa, de 17 años de edad.
El macho al que está acicalando lo dobla en edad,
y es él quien lo eligió como líder.
Está claro que ese macho anciano tiene un poder enorme,
porque fue quien ungió al macho alfa como tal.
El macho de la derecha
es el más fuerte a nivel individual.
Esto se hace evidente cuando están en cautiverio,
porque no tiene conflicto con ninguno de los otros dos.
El conflicto surge cuando aquellos dos están juntos.
Las alianzas que se forman en esa sociedad
hacen que sea más compleja de lo que uno cree.
Esto significa, por ejemplo,
que el macho más pequeño del grupo puede ser el macho alfa.
No hace falta que sea el más grande ni el más fuerte.
Si el más chico mantiene contentos a los amigos adecuados
o si tiene el apoyo de las hembras,
puede ser el macho alfa.
Vemos que el sistema de coaliciones complica las cosas.
Yo siempre espero las primarias aquí en EE. UU.,
el final de las primarias,
porque es el momento en que se debe demostrar unidad.
Primero, vean cómo ellos muestran unidad.
Lo que ven aquí a la izquierda son dos machos
que están juntos.
También vean los grandes dientes caninos que tienen.
Al mostrarse juntos, comunican al resto del grupo
"Estamos juntos. Somos una unidad".
Los machos de la derecha caminan juntos en sincronía.
Esa es otra manera de demostrar que son aliados.
Demostrar unidad es sumamente importante
en un sistema de coaliciones
y, como dije antes, siempre espero ese momento en las primarias
porque luego aparecen dos miembros del mismo partido
que antes se habían enfrentado
y en un momento dado tienen que mostrarse juntos.
Y así se producen situaciones sumamente incómodas.
Personas que no se agradan se ven obligadas a abrazarse
y a mostrarse juntas,
lo cual es fundamental para la unidad del partido,
y si no lo hacen, el partido puede colapsar.
Y si no funciona, como en este caso particular,
(Risas)
el partido tendrá problemas
por no demostrar unidad.
En fin, la unidad es fundamental en el sistema de coaliciones,
y es algo que compartimos con los chimpancés.
Ahora veamos cómo se llega a ser macho alfa.
En primer lugar, es importante impresionar, infundir temor,
demostrar poder cuando sea necesario
y hacer manifestación de fuerza.
Hay muchas formas de hacerlo.
Pero el macho alfa también debe ser generoso.
Por ejemplo, los machos que intentan
derrocar al líder,
una campaña que puede llevar dos o tres meses,
para controlar las coaliciones que se dan en el grupo,
también demuestran una gran generosidad.
Comparten la comida abiertamente con los demás.
O les hacen cosquillas a los bebés de las hembras.
Los chimpancés machos no son particularmente afectos a las crías,
pero cuando están en campaña
se acercan y las divierten de esta manera,
y así se ganan la simpatía de las hembras.
(Risas)
Volviendo a los humanos,
siempre me intrigaron los candidatos varones
que alzan a los bebés así.
No es algo que agrade particularmente a los bebés,
(Risas)
pero como es una señal que será vista en todo el mundo,
tienen que sostener alzado al niño.
Y algo que me llamó la atención,
cuando participó una mujer en las últimas elecciones,
fue que ella tomaba a los bebés en esta posición,
que es la que agrada a los bebés.
Pero, claro, no necesitaba transmitir el mensaje
de que podía sostenerlo sin que se le cayera,
a diferencia del hombre que sí lo necesitaba.
Es una táctica muy común,
y los chimpancés machos
intentan a menudo congraciarse con distintos partidos
cuando están en campaña.
Ahora, ¿cuáles son el precio y los privilegios
de ser un macho alfa?
El mayor privilegio lo constituyen las hembras.
La comida no tiene importancia.
Los machos pueden pasarse una semana sin comer
cuando una hembra está en celo y los machos la pretenden.
La comida es secundaria al sexo.
Los machos actúan de este modo,
según nuestra teoría como biólogos evolucionistas,
porque el sexo conduce a la reproducción
y el éxito reproductivo es la medida de la evolución.
Así es como evoluciona todo.
Y por eso, si los machos mejoran su rol reproductivo
ascendiendo de rango,
automáticamente querrán subir de posición entre los machos.
Ese es el privilegio.
Con respecto al precio que deben pagar,
uno es que deben mantener a los socios contentos.
Así, si alguno llega al poder con el apoyo de un anciano,
pues ese macho anciano podrá aparearse con las hembras.
Si no es así, entonces ese macho se enfadará, retirará su apoyo
y ya dejarán de ser socios.
Así que hay una transacción.
Si el macho llega al rango alfa así, deberá contentar a sus socios.
Ese es un precio que debe pagar.
El segundo es que todos quieren esa posición.
El rango de macho alfa es muy importante,
y todos quieren arrebatarlo,
por eso debe siempre cuidar sus espaldas,
debe estar sumamente alerta.
Por ejemplo, debe disolver las alianzas ajenas,
algo que hacen a menudo.
Aplican la estrategia de "divide y reinarás".
Esta situación genera gran estrés, que pudimos comprobar muy bien
a través de datos obtenidos en el lugar,
con babuinos, no con chimpancés esta vez,
donde se recogieron muestras fecales de los babuinos
y se analizaron los glucocorticoides.
Vemos aquí un gráfico
donde el babuino macho de menor jerarquía
registra los niveles más altos de cortisol
en sus heces.
Pero, como pueden ver, el macho alfa
llega al mismo nivel que el macho de menor rango,
y de esto se podría inferir que ser macho alfa es genial,
pero en realidad es una posición de gran estrés,
lo cual queda demostrado en el plano fisiológico.
Ahora, ¿cuáles son las obligaciones?
Y este aspecto me parece sumamente interesante,
que se aparta de la típica imagen que tenemos del macho alfa.
El macho alfa tiene dos obligaciones.
Una es mantener la paz dentro del grupo.
Le llamamos "rol de control",
o controlar las luchas del grupo.
La segunda es manifestar la mayor empatía posible,
encargarse de consolar a los demás, por decirlo así.
Así que, lo primero es mantener la paz.
Vemos aquí un macho que detiene la lucha entre dos hembras.
Las dos hembras a la izquierda y la derecha
se han estado agrediendo y gritando por comida,
porque la comida es muy importante para ellas,
entonces el macho se interpone y para la pelea de esta manera.
Me parece sumamente interesante que los machos alfa
sean imparciales aquí.
No se inclinan por su madre ni por su mejor amigo.
No, no, detienen la pelea
y, en general, se ponen del lado del más débil.
Esto los hace extremadamente populares dentro del grupo,
porque les da seguridad
a los miembros de menor rango.
Adoptan una postura imparcial,
algo poco común en los chimpancés,
porque en general son muy afectos a sus compañeros,
y estos machos alfa que saben hacerlo
pueden mantener la paz en el grupo de manera efectiva.
La segunda obligación es mostrar empatía por el resto.
Personalmente, me dedico a investigar sobre la empatía,
y no puedo ahora explayarme,
pero la empatía es, hoy día, tema de estudio en roedores, perros,
elefantes y primates,
y muchos otros animales.
Vemos aquí dos bonobos hembras.
La que está adelante
ha sido derrotada en una pelea.
La hembra de atrás la abraza a modo de consuelo.
En realidad, es así como medimos la empatía en los niños,
viendo cómo reaccionan ante el sufrimiento ajeno.
Los machos de alto rango actúan así muy seguido.
Consuelan profundamente a los miembros del grupo
y van a sitios que han sido afectados por terremotos
o huracanes
y allí brindan consuelo.
Lo hace el papa, lo hace el presidente.
Todos los líderes del mundo deben hacerlo.
La reina también lo hace.
Todos tienen que hacerlo,
brindar consuelo, que es una tarea fundamental.
Los machos que cumplen bien estas dos funciones,
mantener la paz y dar consuelo,
se vuelven líderes enormemente populares,
y, en verdad, estas actitudes encierran cierto interés personal.
No lo hacen solo por el grupo,
sino porque además estabiliza su posición.
Cuanto más popular se hace un macho alfa,
y cuanto más admirado y respetado sea por los demás,
tanto más defendido será su lugar
en caso de que algún otro macho pretenda su puesto,
porque, obviamente, tendrá el apoyo de todo el grupo,
que querrá conservar un líder que es bueno para ellos.
El grupo suele ser muy solidario con los buenos líderes,
no así con los machos bravucones.
Cuando los bravucones pierden su posición,
pueden terminar muy mal.
Vemos aquí datos relativos al comportamiento solidario.
Son datos sobre la actitud de consuelo de los chimpancés,
y se observa que, entre los de rango medio y alto,
las hembras son más solidarias que los machos.
Esto aplica a toda la comunidad.
Esto se repite en todos los estudios con mamíferos,
donde las hembras muestran más empatía que los machos.
Pero si miramos al macho alfa,
su conducta es más marcada que la de los demás.
Según los datos, los machos alfa muestran mayor empatía.
Quisiera terminar refiriéndome a las hembras alfa.
Aquí está Mama, la hembra alfa del zoológico de Arnhem,
que era donde trabajaba,
y está ahora por toda Internet.
Llegó a las cien millones de visualizaciones
por un vídeo del momento de su muerte a los 59 años,
ocurrida el año pasado.
Mama era el centro absoluto del grupo.
No tenía la capacidad física de dominar a los machos.
Tenía menor rango que ellos, pero era el centro de todo,
y siempre que había un conflicto
todos terminaban en brazos de Mama.
Era sin duda una figura central.
Por eso, no se debe minimizar la posición de las hembras alfa
en el grupo de los chimpancés.
Y luego tenemos una especie igual de cercana a nosotros
que los chimpancés: los bonobos.
Solemos olvidarlos, pero ellos tienen una sociedad matriarcal
y la figura alfa suele ser una hembra.
Ocupa el rango más alto de la comunidad,
y se tiene muy poca información
sobre cómo acceden a ese lugar y qué funciones cumplen,
porque, en general, la información que tenemos es limitada.
Pero sí quiero remarcar
que la figura alfa del grupo no es necesariamente un macho,
y que, en el caso de estos parientes, es una hembra.
El mensaje que quiero dejarles
es que si un hombre de nuestra sociedad
es el jefe, por ejemplo,
de una familia, una empresa, Washington, o lo que fuere,
y es llamado el "macho alfa",
no deberíamos ofender a los chimpancés
etiquetando equivocadamente.
(Risas)
Un bravucón no debería ser tildado de macho alfa.
Alguien grande y fuerte que intimida e insulta a los demás
no es necesariamente un macho alfa.
Un macho alfa tiene todo tipo de cualidades,
y he visto machos alfa bravucones entre los chimpancés,
los hay,
pero en su mayoría
tienen cualidades de liderazgo
y están integrados a la comunidad,
y al igual que Amos al final,
son queridos y respetados,
que es una situación muy distinta de la que solemos imaginar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)